- Bevor ich ein Restaurant hatte,
hab' ich lange als Koch gearbeitet.
In einem Bistro, das ganz ähnlich aussah
wie euer Restaurant.
- Bevor wir das
Restaurant aufgemacht haben,
hatte ich in einer Firma
als Elektriker gearbeitet.
- Und ich war Bankkaufmann.
- Nein, wirklich? Das ist ja erstaunlich.
Da arbeiten Sie jetzt ja in einem
ganz anderen Beruf.
- Aber es hat sich gelohnt.
- Auch wenn die Gastronomie ganz
schön anstrengend ist.
- Ja, wem sagen Sie das.
Aber man erlebt viel in der Gastronomie.
Bevor ich den Job als Koch hatte,
war ich Spüljunge in der Küche.
Na, das waren Zeiten. Ich könnte
ein Buch drüber  schreiben.
- Ts, deine Biografie will doch
gar keiner lesen.
- Was?
Aber vielleicht interessieren sich die
Menschen ja für meine Erfahrungen.
- Jaques, wir würden es lesen.
Nicht wahr, Max?
- Ganz sicher!
- Da! Zwei Käufer haben wir schon!
- Hey, habt ihr zufällig Nico gesehen?
Er hatte gesagt,
dass er einkaufen wollte.
Er ist jetzt aber schon
seit Ewigkeiten unterwegs.
- Seit er gestern die Sanitäter gerufen hat,
hab' ich ihn nicht mehr gesehen. Du?
- Otto! Was machst du denn hier?
Hallo, Otto! Ich bin's, Yara.
- Entschuldigung, das muss aber eine
Verwechslung sein. Das ist Jacques.
- Nein, ganz sicher nicht. Das ist Otto
aus Duisburg.
Ich kenne ihn schon seit Jahren.
Ich kaufe gebrauchte Fahrräder von ihm ab.
- Inge …
- Sag nicht, dass sie recht hat.
- Was ist denn hier los?
- Das würde ich auch gerne wissen.
- Lass es mich erklären!
Inge!
Inge, warte!